no resignation for you vidit
okay no resignation coming your way
why would you not do that well because
you want to waste some i think if your
air grows and you really do want to
waste time off the match clock oh my
gosh steal me
that's why you don't resign that was
stalemate
oh my gosh oh my instant replay
we have to pull up the analysis board
did you see that coming
no i was i thought like the game is
finished i was reading the chat and then
i hear stalemate i just like i relaxed
because so didn't you queen take c7
check
king a8 and if you're pre-moving g2 here
which
seems to have been what happened after
g2 the king can't move
that is an ingenious trap set by eric
rosen
and now it's a one and a half one half
tie instead of a two to one deficit
oh my gosh vivid are you speechless yeah